hello welcome to UT live I am Sophie she
lacy joining me today our Maddie and Tay
welcome it's so good to see you guys
again it's been way too long new music
out now congratulations oh my a long
time coming
it has and it's been four years I can't
believe this I look this up today it's
been four years since girl in the
country song came out three years since
your debut album now I know you all have
been busy but you did take a beat before
releasing new music so what's been going
on with you why the wait so much life
kind of a crazy story but will give you
like the Cliff Notes version of it so
basically we were with a record label
for you know what three years yes yeah
and that imprint shut down and so we
were left with no label it was pretty
out of the blue - yeah we were planning
on releasing our second record last year
so yeah it all just kind of yeah so so
we were kind of in limbo for a while
trying to figure out like how do we get
music to our fans like it's kind of like
a well it's like getting laid off from a
job where you totally didn't expect it
and you're like wait what is going on
that's like what it felt like so but
long story short we ended up with a
brand new record label that we loved
that really you know they were just like
go make our album that you love and
something that you're passionate about
and so we did and we just hunkered down
for the past year and just really really
made sure that what we wanted to say
this second time around was just spot-on
to what we were going through the past
couple years and I mean you know how we
are we're very like vulnerable and
honest and yeah keep it very unfiltered
so we wanted this album to be exactly
that again crazy cuz even the music we
had gone and cut half of a record back
in 2016
did you have to scrap that whole thing
yeah wow I'm glad we did cuz even that
music it felt like we grew out of it so
quickly just because in life that we
were living in that moment but yeah it
was me three is a very different very
pivotal year for young woman and I feel
like you know the record that we have
now it's a big one but it's a story and
we
wouldn't be able to tell that story
without going through couple hardships
yeah well I love the new single it's
called friends don't why was that the
perfect reintroduction to Maddie and Tay
so like Tay was saying the album's a
story so it starts off with the who's
gonna make the move
friends don't moment the whole records
in the I it's through the eyes of a
relationship so it starts out in love
the friends don't think and then it kind
of goes into this heartbreak phase which
is kind of what we went through with all
that crazy label stuff and then the end
of the record is like a big redemptive
anthemic part where the girl in the
record gets her power bracket it's kind
of a comedy yeah the two of but yeah
friends don't we just felt like it's the
first chapter in the story record and
it's a love song we never released a
love song as a single before we had
horses come out none of them were about
a relationship about love so it's like
okay we're back and we're singing about
different things now you mean you may
know us this side of us but here's the
completely different side so it's nice
but I hope it's still like I feel like
you guys are known for being really
empowering oh yeah I know the cool thing
with friends don't is it's a different
take like it's not the girl that's
waiting for the guy to make the move
like in that and friends don't it's like
I know you dig me and I did you too so
come on let's make like yeah there's
still that like kind of strength yeah
yes I love it okay so we are looking
forward to seeing the music video it's
done when you shot it already okay
yes got the final like we have to get it
like color corrected and all that fancy
stuff but we just got like the final cut
today and I watch it at least once a day
I'm just so excited yes we act in it
yeah we are the like main character yes
it's very different from all the music
videos we've done okay well tell me a
little more about it I'm so excited to
see it well Maddie and I both have
different storylines I'm not gonna give
away too much okay juice but we both
have different storylines but in the
same setting so the music video will
kind of follow Maddie story
and my story and yeah the conclusions
you'll just have to wait to see okay
both have a love interest and that OVR
of course friends don't so you've had
love interests that are not your real
life no matter we were not gonna put our
guys do that that was that like were
their ground rules set like I mean you
know it's all professional yeah yeah and
thankfully we hired real actors and they
were very professional and gentlemen and
yeah it was fine yeah yeah yeah everyone
always says like the least sexy thing in
the world is like getting romantic on
camera it was yeah I'm like Tay she's
actually a really really good actress
like she should do it like she should go
do the acting yeah but yeah I don't
enjoy it like I but we needed to do it
for this song and for the video we had
to be the main characters in it for it
to make sense
uh-huh sounds like okay I'm just gonna
like do the best I can you know I was so
nervous so nervous cuz it's so not like
I can't be anything other than myself
like to a fault uh so I was like okay
I've got to get it together because we
do want to act in more videos cuz I feel
like it's more personal when the harvest
is like telling the story as the artist
and you know in the video I think it
feels a little more personal so it was
our first ever night shoot too
so we started at 3 p.m. and Maddy
wrapped her last scene at what 585 yeah
Wow
a long one where your guys there where
they jealous at all okay oh they weren't
there yeah I know they seen it yeah skip
that one
my family is Cena I'm totally the kind
of girl that likes to surprise people so
kind my parents know like with anything
when we got a record deal I waited till
we had actual contract to show them
because yes I love like shocker and
surprising so I'll wait to share it with
my peeps fun well I see some fan
questions coming through so please keep
them coming you guys I'm going to ask as
many as we possibly can let's ask this
one from Riya I'm Rhea what is your
favorite new song to perform live
there's a Bop yeah these are our girls
Jill and they're like hard fans alright
we're gonna do both
questions I love that you guys recognize
my favorite is new dogs that's an but I
don't know because friends don't kind of
fun to play now because people are
starting to recognize it yeah it so I
think it'd be between those two for me
yeah I'm gonna have to say we have a
song called everywhere I'm going okay
well now this question is from Jill what
is each of your favorite songs that will
be on the new album
my favorite song I'm not gonna say the
title because they haven't played it yet
yeah okay heartbreak yeah it's in the
heartbreak chapter I love that you guys
were able to channel kind of the
heartbreak of the late because you are
so happy in your relationships we were
able to channel the heartbreak of the
label into this music that had to be
really therapeutic for you guys I would
imagine so I mean you think about
heartbreak and you think about a
romantic relationship no I mean it can
come with anything especially your
career because you tie yourself so much
into that you know Mom especially this
industry like in any type of
entertainment industry like you're
always like you know you tie yourself
worth to it so it was like losing a
loved one
yeah do you have a date for the new
album no we're thinking first quarter
though yeah next year hopefully the end
of this year beginning of next year
sometime around there very exciting okay
so Maddie congratulations are in order
can we get a close-up on the ring you
guys look at how beautiful it is it's
shining so did you know like okay did
you pick out the ring did he pick out
the ring so okay Jonah and I have been
together since we were sophomores in
high school so when I moved off to
Nashville we were like okay we are in it
to win it we're gonna make this happen
so we've it our seven-year anniversary
was May 23rd we always forget maybe a
sound then yeah we always just say May
20 something but anyways so we were
talking about it for the past
year or so about getting engaged getting
married Beauvoir and I just didn't think
that it was gonna like we had gone and
looked at rings and tried them on and
all this we actually have a song on the
record called trying on ring something
all about our love story and everything
anyway we wrote that song the day after
we went looked at rings for the first
time so it was just like oh my gosh it's
crazy
but anyway so our seven year University
was coming up and we went to Cabo for
vacation and so he proposed the night
before we left for Cabo
so I thought it was just an anniversary
trip but we he turned it into like an
engagement celebration yeah yeah totally
that's so fun did you know he was gonna
do it I knew that the ring was made okay
this is my mom's original stone from her
original ring but my dad has upgraded
her since I was 25 years you better but
really smart and did not tell the best
friend because I would have yeah I mean
I wouldn't have told you but you would
have been able I would have grilled her
yeah yeah to read me so you didn't tell
me when but I knew the ring was made so
that's like any day now yeah you're just
trying to keep it to yourself that's
well the fans want to know too sandy
says how excited are you to be getting
married so yes you know I know we just
yeah we booked the venue today I'll be
getting married oh that was today.you
birthday Wow yes we just like signed the
contracts and everything but we're gonna
do it next fall so and then tazed gonna
go look at dresses with me soon she's
one of my bridesmaids oh okay I was
gonna ask what kind of rolls yeah I'm
like I should stop saying that because
you need to do like the whole like gift
and the presentation yes I know I have
like a great idea for all my bridesmaids
but I'm like I mean everyone already
knows if their bridesmaids yeah yeah
it's hard to keep that in it's so
exciting I know just like I mean of
course you're gonna be a bridesmaid why
would you not like I'm doing the full
like 150 people wedding okay
how BIG's your bridal party 7-7 on
outside yes okay I am obsessed with the
number 7 it's so it's only right I
well and it was just hard because it was
like I have so many great women in my
life that I want standing next to me
well I have one sister and then my
fiancee has three so yeah so that's
already four right there so I had seven
too so I think that's good luck I know
yeah I was born on 77 like yeah there's
birthday really yes I was gonna yeah and
happy birthday to you I was gonna say
actually you just celebrated a birthday
take out me the cutest gifts ever so so
lame but I really wanted a fanny pack
for my birthday
poster picture yes and so she got me
like a workout fanny pack and like a
really cute fashionable one oh I'm a
great listener yeah so I just listened
and then she says what she wants and
then I get it friends buy the best gift
jolly yes now so how else are the
wedding plans looking right now like you
have a lot of time before you're gonna
get there but I feel like you can do a
lot in the beginning and then there's
kind of a law you're being smart by kind
of getting a lot of stuff out of the way
yeah not worried really stuff like that
right not to be like okay well I've
heard that if you booked like the venue
and catering and stuff it's cheaper if
you do it earlier because the prices
just go up and up and the closer it gets
to the date for some reason wedding tip
booked it as early as possible and you
get your pick of vendors yes yeah
totally totally so I don't know we're
just trying to knock some of it out so
then we can just kind of enjoy when you
go to yes girl
tasting - that is the most fun part I
love it I think it's so funny because
the last time I saw you guys I was
planning my wedding so we were talking
all about my and now we're talking all
about yours you don't have to give me
all the tips and everything oh I'm full
of them girl hook you up cuz today
whenever she eventually gets married
she's like eloping she a wedding really
the most I think I do is like a very
intimate immediate family only okay be
like a big party yeah definitely a
celebration but who knows to me though
they're so intimate and I'm such a
reserved person I feel like it would be
hard to stand in front of other people
and like say speak from the heart which
I feel I do every night on stage but
right it's different
now how about you are you guys feeling
the pressure to like take the next up to
talk about it well we definitely talk
about it okay I wouldn't but ya know we
talked about it no pressure though yeah
like we're just excited to celebrate
Maddie's birthday yeah he's so fun
her boyfriend Josh is so cute though
because we we actually wrote two songs
on the album because he yes song we
wrote two of the songs on the record
with him but we just wrote recently and
every time Tay would have like a
brilliant line or just like something
amazing he'd be like oh man my knees
hurting I'm like why he's like cuz I'm
about to have to get down on it I was
like oh cheesy romantic yeah but it's
good for her cause she's very like sauce
ya know to the yang yeah balance each
other out
totally absolutely you're more romantic
or your husband ah my husband's pretty
good yeah I have a boy like my fiance's
way more like romantic I actually have
to try and think about how to be like
you managed the girl ya know but girls
want to be swept off their feet right
good point yeah okay I love this
question that just came in from Julia
she says in your own words how would you
all describe your fashion senses on a
budget I love finding really cute
outfits for not a lot of money or having
like a really nice shoe paired with like
a cheap dress yeah yeah yeah yeah good
jeans with like a discounted shirt and
stuff I love a bargain but where do you
bargain hunt forever21
t.j.maxx is a good one you can find some
really great big brands there like I
love dresses so I would say like
romantic edge I don't know okay it meets
meets in the middle
but I like to be edgy yeah I would say
mine's like a little more edgy like I've
been trying to like like not be so
covered up all the time
I can just you know showing it a
shoulder you guys always complement each
other to like I feel like that much just
come naturally for you guys at this
point everyone did y'all plan this yes
that happened before in the same jeans
on stage yeah multiple times
okay so naturally this makes me wonder
about the wedding dress like what kind
of style do you see yourself in I want
something like super simple I think
since we get to play dress up like two
to three times a year for work shows and
stuff I don't want anything like super
poufy or like anything - I just want
something really comfortable and just
real simple and classic but because I
want to change into like a white
jumpsuit that's like like Losey you do
time Laird yes so then I can like bust a
move at the reception because we're
trying to have my fiancees Puerto Rican
and those Puerto Ricans they party into
the night like I have to have a dress
that I can get down okay how are you
gonna be when she's trying on dresses
are you gonna be like waterworks
I think she's gonna be annoyed with me
because every dress like this is the one
so excited yeah it's so hard I think
there's a lot of pressure to have like
the one dress but they're all so
beautiful I know you're never wrong
I feel like I'm I mean I don't know I'm
saying this now I haven't even gone and
looked at dresses yet just like only on
pincers and stuff but I don't know if
I'm gonna have that just because I've
done that so many times with red carpets
I mean you know
like yeah it's like you just pick a
dress and rock and roll so I think
you'll probably count on the people that
are there to be like yeah this looks
great
yeah but I'm so like petite like I can't
have something to flowy ours just gonna
like eat me and I'm just like a little
nugget like oh yeah totally arms and
shoulders oh girl please put a ton of
highlighter and making there you go
beauty tip what about music at the
wedding when you're mourning oh no okay
I don't know I think because we do it
for a living I just want like a really
great DJ that's gonna play like from
cardi B to like George Jones like that
whole no absolutely not no I'm not even
gonna give a speech like me and Jonah
we're like we're just gonna do like the
regular vowels like keep it real simple
like you love Jesus I love Jesus we love
the other call it a day break it down
have some drinks and there we go the
best night ever totally just very casual
I don't know I don't want anything too
fancy I feel like it's just too much
work yeah it's a lot of pressure yeah I
don't want to do that you're doing a
right girl where are you having it we
are doing it out in Nashville perfect
yeah yeah a lot of our family from Texas
is gonna have to drive up and but we're
like sorry folks we are not planning
away difficult no and that's your homes
yeah perfect totally Danny yeah well now
that we've had all our girl-talk
thank you guys so much for being here
I'm so excited about the new music next
year we're thinking for the album yeah
okay so yeah and then the music video
for friends don'ts coming so yeah
excited all right stay tuned you guys
thank you so much for watching and we'll
see you next time
bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you